hello everyone around one of the singles
cup of the rapid section just ended and
it was a very eventful round Fabiano
cora wanna manage to lose a completely
winning position against Fort Wayne
William Louisianans had a had a very
nice position against the car Nakamura
but Nakamura managed tactically outplay
him and win the game as part of drew his
game against Sergey Karjakin and well
the star of the round one was definitely
eleven R&M he plays he played a
brilliant game against the David navara
and well he just sacrificed the piece
and the one the game like it was nothing
so so does the game I want to show you
our engine is white and the Navara is
black we have d4 by our Onion Knight to
f6 c4 e6 we have Knight to f3 and now b6
the Queen's Indian defense g3 Bishop
today a6 b3 Bishop to b4 check Bishop to
d2 Bishop back three seven and now
Knight to c3 so we have castles Bishop
to g2 d5c capture some d5e capture some
d5 and castles and rotate we have nice
to e5 Bishop back to b7 Queen to c2 and
I'll see five it's a very nice move as
it's well prepares to develop the knight
and it freezes freezes bishop and well
he's going for this d4 pawn that white
has isolated for now D captures on c5 by
RM b captures on c5 and rook a to d1 we
have Queen to c8 and now II four which
is the faith and now attacking the
knight first so our engine place at four
and we have d4 and well this is the
critical position of the game and this
is where our onion finds a beautiful
idea he plays nice to d5 we have nine
chapters on d5e capture some d5 and s6
and this F six
well now I thought that this was a
pretty good idea because after the
knight moves for example let's say to c4
or somewhere then simply Queen to d7 and
this is okay for black
but Aragon said that even if like didn't
player six Aragon was considering to
sacrifice the knight on f6 and after the
team captures simply captured with the
Queen on h7 and this would expose the
black king but Navarro played f6 and in
this tradition Aragon said that if he
was playing a classical game then he
would think about his next move but as
if it was as if it was a rapid game he
decided to play a rogue detaii one
immediately so now I accepted arrogance
all four he played F captures on e5 f
captures on e5 and ok black is up a
piece but what has this D pawn and this
e pawn and it's a very nice Center and
it's a rapid game and you have to play
the correct moves if you if you want to
survive this as black but navara plays a
bad move right right from the start he
plays it nice at d7 and this allows our
going to play e6 with tempo we have nice
to f6 and Knight to f6 is a good move
because I mean this f6 Square is great
for the night but this is a this is the
old part of our another idea he plays
rook captures on f6g captures on f6 and
now Queen to f5 and this Queens f5 is a
is a really strong move it has more
protection to this d5 pawn it eyes this
h7 point and it is preparing Bishop to
e4 in some very near future so we have
twin to d8 and our enemies in plays rook
to e4 preparing rook to g4 or rock to h4
depending on what black place we have
rook to e7 and roof the g4 check and
well no more I had to spend some time
here to calculate and after some time he
plays the King to h8 but it
interestingly if if he decided to play
rook to g7 and defend like this our
onion has a force checkmate in 8 moves
and it's really not that difficult to
find it you can try it if you want
he would play Bishop to e4 and now the
there's no way to stop a checkmate on h7
because the Queen can't seem to capture
this rook is pinned so black wouldn't
really have any moves he would simply
have to play rook to g6 and after
recaptures on g 6h captures Queen
captures Bishop to g7 and our Bishop
date six threatening checkmate on g7 the
Queen would have to defend somehow and
now simply Queen to h7 check the King
has to go back Queen to h8 and now the
mission this Bishop is pinned so the
King has to go to e7 and our Queen
captures here Queen King 36 and simply
push up to f4 checkmate
I don't know if ours and so the entire
sequence but this is completely winning
for my for white regardless of what
black plays but Navarro Saudis and the
probe g4 to play the King to h8 onion
immediately plays Bishop to Bishop to g4
because there's really no point in
capturing here on f6 with check this
would simply allow blacks to play Bishop
to g7 and well play Bishop to g7 with
the temple and black can't play Bishop
to g7 while the queen is on f5 because
Bishop to g7 Queen captures and h7 is
the instance checkmate so okay we have
Bishop d4 here by Aragon and now rook
the c-4 by Navarro he wants to get his
rook into the game because well he is up
for work now but as long as his rookies
on aah it's really not up for work and
Aragon here just plays rook to h4 with
an added attack on h7 and Navarre plays
King to g8 there's really no point in
trying to defend h7 with a move like
Queen to c7 because this would only
improve White's position after after
move like Bishop f4 where's the Queen
going to go looking Queen has to go back
to the 8th and what didn't really
accomplish anything
so after up to h4 noir played King to g8
and Arjun simply capture the pawn rook
captures and h7 here in Navarro tries to
give some material back Bishop captures
and e5 but Aragon isn't interested in
material he simply goes and finishes the
game Queen to g6 check we have a rock to
g7 and now are in a simple place Queen
to h5 and there is no way to stop
checkmate mhh so Navarre played one more
move just to allow Aragon to check
making he played Bishop captures on e4
and are immediately played rook
rub the h8 checkmate so yeah definitely
a beautiful game and well again Ariane
starts the tournament with with the most
brilliant game and the most beautiful
winner of the round so yeah a beautiful
game and hope hope this continues
through the entire tournament and we'll
see around to is about to start and
let's see if Gary can can accomplish
anything
so yeah that's it as usual you can check
to my previous videos here I do hope you
enjoyed it thank you all for watching
and I'll see you soon